from what I understand this mean okay
it's off that your daav button whatever
you set that to just you just jump
straight up and if you have them on kick
kick while you're in the air you go
forward and if you just press kick you
jump backwards wait and it just blows
out one second yeah go ahead okay whoa
what a nice Wow Hey whoa that's amazing
okay Oh what happened
Chacho resumed in why is it zoom merely
a five-second turn something wrong
happened with my resolutely diving s
kicking ass not losing on I the winner
well I hope you're happy
oh yeah well I'm going with the boot man
until I beat you oh nice color nice yeah
he's that man you don't want to sit next
to on an airplane DIF okay
can this time know what it's so laggy
Kenji chill out cos it's so laggy for me
the line for you come here what it looks
like you're [ __ ] me I can't even do
anything it's not fair stop jumping oh
you you pop a balloon I'm so mad
oh it still pops oh yeah you're not
getting that [ __ ] back what the heck
okay oh my fat oh my fat that's the
worst thing that could happen
oh jeez how do you even do that
I hit both the buttons the same time oh
it's so laggy for me why isn't it lying
for you it said like hey my feet you hit
my Oh Pete was it right a little nuts
right in the nuts
ah yay you're stupid a handstand why
wouldn't I
oh it's why do you think I have boots I
don't need these boots anymore yes socks
in your hands not losing D I happen and
notorious used what or except I guess
score all right 10% dime why not
so kick I don't know this oh I can see
my nice oh oh and you're like man you're
drilling a lot man
yeah yeah it's a solid pants me look at
them panties
oh come here you can look at all I'll
jump fast whoa what the [ __ ] are you do
well where'd you go I don't even know
see I can jump now I'm like a bird
i think those gusy gone I was too
mesmerized by those panties yea-ah drunk
I would be taken hey you like smell
straight across I only go like up and
down panty power I don't understand the
controls but I know exactly what I'm
doing the 10% dab you gotta whatever's
awesome
that's obviously knotting it Ken it's
pure skill go natural boys I'm sorry
what he's waiting on me
no yes come here Ken I'll give you my
panties they're ready
oh really Who am I cred just like bulls
you're attracted to it you want what is
that guy doing in the [ __ ] bag you
see some panties
I'll be going throw this party are you
dude what I was a dude no I don't think
so man
dr. Schultz yeah that's you know dr.
Scholl's are uh no I do not
they're like shoe inserts to make your
feet people why is she mad oh I
understand that okay what a table Jame
give me that come on I gotta I'm gonna
prove you that it's not the dive gem
okay I don't have genitals apparently
that's good I'm really curious what like
no went through their head when they
made your chest I said you know what
let's make it oh [ __ ] no look at me damn
you Thank You Lana kicking I don't
understand what's going on we're kicking
just right into dentistry you don't have
one you're not gonna help them and you
keep riding it even though you're dead
take it
stop died kicking woman OH
dodge dodge take it come on this is
ridiculous ken what are we doing I
thought oh come on
Oh that'll work sign I literally was
just about to hear you
that is uncle stop it Oh Oh
murders you look you're happy of course
I am the planet alive yes oh come on
that's just [ __ ] [ __ ] I mean go
and make some shoes I'm done here I had
a beard before I even started liking
girls wow this guy is me change your
panties got the same ones only had last
time
gross hey you like it oh my god books
yt organs oh oh oh
there's not even a [ __ ] what
nuttin oh I don't know why I won that
but I'd take it I don't think my actual
kick hurts you I think it's the
Lightning behind me there - oh that
doesn't make any sense
but yeah you're right like fly across Oh
keep doing the dirt not okay with this
nineteen my tits why is that you can't
believe it ah labor I'm gonna get you
thought any more about okay look at my
back but look at that butt Wow
this belt let the championship belt I
have on [ __ ] hates you oh good oh
come on let's get bigger why don't I get
anything cool
something cool please what the [ __ ]
check out my Bomboy hate why why yeah
[ __ ] yeah oh oh go down head if I go
down I think I got the lamest character
in ever
look at my kicks like wait o33
perfect of course it was perfect I mean
we don't have a life bar so so do you
mean oh it's not even a kid and bigger
that was it hi that thing is gonna pop
that better [ __ ] hot I'm looking at
you never again never again again oh no
see go away see if I give a [ __ ] don't
go with of course yes I you fine ok it's
you and you're me it's got the backwards
blue hat and everything I love this
hands wait we're both like the racial
representations of ourselves I mean that
I try to say something but it didn't
work
this is my red sneakers why are there
most [ __ ] in the background why are
they really oh look at that right ha ha
works every time
oh it's on now and they're just nudging
back there they're not are you sure
maybe you should check again what you
shut your face
Oh take my real shot my face Sam put my
Jordans all up into the grill
gangsta okay I can't even jump that high
what is the matter oh oh come on are you
Oh take that a basketball how about that
is it because you're a mean one
I don't get it what's up why is it
in some zooming in you stupid [ __ ]
game I can't even see what I have right
on the ass really why'd you stay assumed
II don't get it
it all comes down it does doesn't it
yeah your sucker
well [ __ ] [ __ ] you mad he mad
no I didn't I barely even flinched I'm
tall and stop
Camille [ __ ] crush I'll climb here
it's not real man climb you haven't seen
[ __ ]